devant
[Musique]
colgate movie faux ce n'est que 5e pour
l'émission je vais là dieu ou la balance
yagg à col mao
la france ne peut plus accueillir toute
la misère du monde la france que j'aime
c'est la france qui partage qui
accueillent à bras ouverts c'est à dire
le type de mon dernier arrêté l'enfumage
pourquoi vous ne donnez pas l'exemple
prenez-en chez vous écoutez c'est très
simple si une famille de roms et dans le
besoin ce soir elle est la bienvenue
chez moi
2 allée des roses à marnes-la-coquette
personne enfin ma part mes invités ron
je la subis par les piques vers istres
france baisse des prix et leur bras
ouverts merci merci à tous
[Musique]
c'est mortel et des roms qui ont ainsi
pu me fait pas peur collinet c'est
mortel